(soft music)
- [Hudda] I vividly remember
the Civil War in Somalia.
Of course there was fear there.
It was not a safe place for us.
And that's the reason why
we left our own country.
- [Minnie] When Hudda landed in the U.S.
she had no idea that her
neighbors would be afraid of her.
- I have been told that
there are certain customs
in the Somali culture that
I'm not supposed to transgress
and I don't know what they are.
- I think we need to know
more about their religion,
where they're coming from
because I was understood
you never ever shake hands.
- People are genuinely
interested in getting to know us
that's why they're coming
to Dine and Dialogue
in large numbers.
We wanna help them overcome
the fear of unknown.
My name is Hudda Ibrahim and
I started Dine and Dialogue
and I'm a refugee from Somalia.
(dramatic music)
- My name is Minnie Driver.
I am an actress, a singer
and I am an immigrant.
I believe nothing is more
American than its immigrants.
So I'm teaming up with
Great Big Story to celebrate
those that have come
here and left their mark.
(soft music)
- [Hudda] I was 19 years old
when I came to Minnesota.
It was a long journey.
- [Minnie] During the Somali Civil War
large numbers of Somalis
relocated to Minnesota.
Today the state has the largest population
of Somalis in North America.
But the influx of Somali refugees
has created tension in the community.
- Moving into this central
Minnesota community
people are curious about our culture
and who we are and where we came from.
Of course we do have challenges.
I am Muslim, I am black, I am a refugee,
but I'm also Somali American.
So instead of being angry and complaining
my husband and I turned
it to the other side
and said we should do
something about this.
- [Minnie] So Hudda and her husband
started Dine and Dialogue, a
bi-monthly dinner gathering
where the St. Cloud community
can meet their Somali neighbors.
- People were afraid to ask questions
that they thought were
inappropriate or offensive.
And when individuals usually
come to those dinners
we say, ask us any burning
questions that you might have.
Questions like, what is the
significance of the hijab?
Why do Muslims pray five times a day?
So instead of assuming, I
want people to be open minded.
The first Dine and Dialogue
we didn't know who was coming,
we just sent an open invitation to all.
My husband and I couldn't believe
when we saw 50 registration
and we were like we need to make sure
that we have enough food
for these people coming.
- [Minnie] Hudda helps
cook a massive Somali meal
for all who attend.
And she attributes some
of her program's success
to the meals themselves.
- Food is one of the main contributors
really bringing people together.
There were a lot of people who told me
that they never had any Somali food before
and that they love the sambusa.
We make sure that the
sambusas are ready to fry.
When we make rice we make sure
that we have the right meat,
we have goat meat.
We make sure that we
have chicken and beef,
veggie and Somali tea.
So do not leave this room
today without knowing someone,
so get to know your
neighbors, ask questions,
thank you very much.
- I feel that I want to be compassionate,
I feel that I want to
care, I'm just afraid
that I'm gonna do something
that's gonna offend somebody.
- Once you're open to the idea
of somebody being different
then there's more common than
there is actually differences.
- But if you are afraid to make a mistake
and they're afraid to make a mistake,
then there is a disconnection.
- [Minnie] Today she continues to host
this open forum every other month
and hopes to expand
into other communities.
- I'm hoping to spread Dine and Dialogue
throughout Minnesota.
I devoted my life to build a
better community for all of us.
And I want people to know
that we're proud Americans,
we're taxpayers, we're
contributing to the economy
and that we're here to stay.
(upbeat music)
(bell ringing)